i'm here to talk about electronic mines
so first of all i'm gonna i'm gonna kill
the buzz right now
deep learning is hyped it's marketed and
people go crazy with it
and honestly it's it's not useful for
everything
um so i'd like to disclaimer up front
that i'm not here to try to sell you
deep learning
i'm not here to try to tell you it's
good for everything
it'll give you the most accuracy it's
automatic
i'm here to tell you what it's good for
what i use it for
and some really cool applications so
that being said um i'll just give you
like a two second spiel like
basically um so i dropped out of school
started and i'm basically self-taught
machine learning so now i teach
at now i teach part-time at a machine
learning bootcamp um
with python and then i do a lot of like
basically like java jvm big data stuff
so that's kind of like my background so
if you have any particular questions let
me know
um that being said so i'm not a
researcher
i'm a practitioner so i'm here to say
i'm going to give you something useful
to look forward to not a bunch of math
equations that says
oh this does this if you do this no i'm
here to just tell you
this neural net is good for that and
here here's why deep learning is good
so with that preface out of the way um
i'd like to start
by saying deep learning is awesome um
primarily used for media so all the
breakthrough results that you've seen
are all media so sound images
text unstructured data not customer
churn
not dealing with a lot of like data that
you'd see in databases and spreadsheets
you can use it for forecasting it's
great for like time series and all sorts
of other crazy stuff like that
but the primary applications are media
so with that in mind so
deep learning is not automatic like
basically cognitive intelligence like
they claim it is
deep learning is basically uns basically
there's there's two components to it
there's an unsupervised component and a
supervised component
so the unsupervised component is where
all the hype comes from
one com one thing i'm going to talk
about tonight is this idea of
representation learning
so just to kind of get an idea of the
audience like how many of you guys
i i'm not gonna i'm not here to insult
you i swear i just i really need to know
what i'm
kind of getting at here how many of you
guys know what a feature vector is
okay this is gonna make my life so much
easier okay
so basically representation learning
basically takes a feature vector
and then it learns its own non-linear
inputs
or features so neural nets are pre
are basically parametric models uh
basically it's logistic regression
with basically 10 matrices
um so the unsupervised learning part
i'll get into in a bit
is actually really cool but it's not
cognitive intelligence it's
itself learns in a way but it's not what
we'd normally think of
so in this case it's pattern recognition
it's saying like oh if i repeatedly
sampled from this data enough
i can learn its structure so that's this
idea of representation learning what i
want to do is show
a different a few different
visualizations in that respect and kind
of give you an idea of like what is a
representation and then like
what are like what are feat like how
does it learn features
so there's this just to kind of quantify
where for those of you who haven't
aren't familiar with the literature
where a lot of the hype comes from is
people are like oh
it like learned what a cat is right
that's actually representation learning
yes it can look at youtube videos and
yes it can like roughly recognize a cat
that's actually a bunch of sampling with
mcmc that's really all it is for those
of you who know what mcmc is
that's that's powering a lot of like
deep learning applications or sam like
representation learning
um so how many of you guys saw like uh
andrew ing's like new york
like new york times article on like
learning what a cat is from youtube
hands come on okay so i'm gonna show
i'll i'll show you like i'll show you
enough cats that you'll that you'll be
satisfied we're all here for cats
um because that's what deporting is
right so
but in general like um that's like so
that's this idea representation learning
so deep learning um one of the problems
with it
is it's very hard there's literally over
30 different hyper parameters a given
neural net will have
and any number of combination for
different sorts of neural nets
so i'm going to show kind of like the
overview tonight of different neural
nets
what they're used for how you visualize
like like what they're thinking about
and everything else
so like i mentioned deporting is cats so
we see a picture
we see but a neural net sees pixels
so it's like how do we basically what's
really cool about neural nets is
i can show it a set of pixels and it
will learn how to reconstruct those
pixels
those pixels can be then be used for
feature recognition
in photos so i'll show a couple
different examples of scene parsing
object recognition um if you guys want
like something cool to look up
look up uh facebook's deep face research
uh so that's actually a paper
that shows that deep learning can
actually beat human accuracy
in individual facial recognition of
individual people
another one is the imagenet challenge um
by the way can you guys hear me
i just wanna okay okay cool um
so so another one is the imagenet
challenge so
imagenet is a set of over 200 class
label classes
of images with a huge number of photos
it's a competition that's held every
year
and deep learning actually just beat
human accuracy in that
as well the problem with so what
basically deep learning is a replacement
for a lot of manual hacks that are very
brittle
so when i say feature extraction i mean
sift
i mean a lot of like hacky natural
language processing features like
this ending with that beginning and this
in the middle and
this word before that word and like you
know this is a replacement for a lot of
like manual hacks
that no one wants to spend their time
doing so um
i also work with a lot of people who do
sound and audio like speech to text
background noise detection
things in that space as well and they
told me basically like look we have 150
features we've created
and we've done these over the course of
a number of years
and it doesn't scale so deep learning is
actually
just a really cool layer on top of a lot
of like crazy hacks that people have
done
and people spent a lot of their time and
resources in
and investing in um so deep learning is
a great replacement for that
deep learning with like in this case
like you know these pixels and all that
i can show an ever expanding number of
pixels i can show it different
orientations
and it will actually learn what those
pixels are so it's basically just a more
robust version
of crazy hacks so it's like we can
either
we can do two things we can either have
something that's not human interpretable
like okay we all love random forest
so random forest i can like inspect the
individual nodes i can visualize them
i can even print out if statements that
basically represent what like what the
random force learns
that's great for feature introspection
what about for text and all other sorts
of things where there's all sorts of
like nasty interactions that you have to
deal with
so that is what deep learning is good
for is saying okay
let me take all these nasty interactions
and learn a general representation of
that
so does that does that sort of like make
sense like what representation learning
is like
you know like i show a pic i see a cat
it's pixels
you know it basically takes human
interpretable data that's very easy for
us to
measure look at interpret and it
basically
maps that onto a feature vector
so again just to kind of go a little bit
more in depth
uh just in in general like what deep
learning and like at least what i
what i'm an advocate of using it for um
so
basically think of something on your
computer so every form of unstructured
unstructured data usually takes some
form of a document
so let's just say it's your music folder
so what does that music folder have like
let's just say
i have let's just say i want to do
classification of rock music and i want
to do it based on
the raw audio well what does that look
like
so that data set is actually going to be
maybe like let's just say like
i have rock i have um
jazz you know it's like i have several
different i have several different
folders
and my goal then is to basically take
the mp3s that are in those folders and
say the parent directory of that folder
is the label or of that file is the
label right
so i want to do that based on the raw
audio signal so i show a neural net a
song i play the neural i play the song
for the neural net
and it learns a set of features that's
literally what you do you play the song
it learns the features and then and then
you say that's that's audio or that's uh
that's jazz
and what it will do is it'll be like oh
that's jazz okay
and then what what deep learning is good
for is actually learning those general
representations so it will pick up on
all the patterns like
oh um so this like from one minute
three to one minute six like did this
like really weird like loud sound so
that's what deep learning is good at
picking up are those general patterns so
it will
actually if i show it more data it will
actually scale
so when you see google and all these
guys doing deep learning you know
it's actually them saying let's show it
a bunch of unstructured data
and have it learn a good general set of
features
so another thing is forecasting so
forecasting is i don't know if you guys
have seen this or not
this idea of backpropagation through
time so this idea of saying
okay i have back propagation with a
neural net and i want it to remember
what it learned
so this is actually a representation of
if
you guys are interested i can show you
after but basically google bought a
startup called deepmind for 400 million
and what they did was they actually
basically
created a player for artari games and
they did it
by showing it repeated clips of
basically gameplay
that represented what good and bad
looked like and then it was actually
able from there to learn the patterns
and then it actually like
generated something that was actually
literally a player
so it learned basically a moving window
of the signal
right so another thing on that same note
is sensors so sensors is all time series
right so it's like
you know it's a it's a raw signal of
some kind you know the signal that
happened at time
t minus one to t to t plus one we want
to forecast t plus one
so sensor data you know could be in my
phone right where it's like
it's picking up like where i'm stepping
right now where i'm moving
what i'm speaking about all that is
signal processing
so basically recurrent nets in this case
are very
like i'll go into those a little bit
more later i'm just kind of doing like
an overview right now
um basically i'm really good at like
signal processing time series
and remembering what it learned
um i guess like i'll cover one more
um so i guess what i'll do i'll also do
text
so i'll also i'll show you that later
but like what i want to do is like
so text i want to do text classification
so again i have a
set of documents a corpus so this is all
for unstructured data so
this this so this unstructured data
could live on your hard drive it could
learn
you could live in s3 wherever you have
data hdfs
doesn't matter key point here is that
usually like unstructured data you
might have some kind of a label or and
we have we have trends we want to
extract from it
so text is in that same boat so
automatic feature extraction of from
media
unstructured data anything that doesn't
live in a database and has
an explicit set of values like
categorical or what have you
does that does that sort of like make
sense like what
what what the primary use case is what
it's good for
did like unstructured data everything's
like in a like usually in a hierarchy
it's usually like a file of some kind
you know we we use it for things
and it's human interpretable
so what are some actual applications of
this so immediately one thing i love
bringing up is the netflix challenge
deep learning back in 2007 won the
netflix challenge
so everybody uses collaborative filters
for recommenders
uh depending on if you're doing graph
analysis or not with like triangle
closing or what have you
um people have actually used something
called a restricted bolt machine
to learn and reconstruct user like user
features
so like you know it's like you know you
typically use like nmf or something
where
you know you basically learn you
basically learn how to fill in empty
values
deep learning is also very good at that
recently
also spotify started using deep learning
for recommenders as well
and they did it based on your playlist
so they were like you played this song
with these features
at this time and this is the likelihood
that you will play
like you you might want to play this
song like look so
what what is that good for so like if
i'm in a if i'm in a bad mood
and i'm playing like a lot of like heavy
metal and all that like you know
i'm going to want it to pick up on those
trends deep learning will automatically
figure all that out for you and it will
figure out those feature interactions
so what representation learning is good
for is figuring out feature
interactions so you have a set of
coefficients that basically learn how to
represent the data um and then it can it
can actually pick up on like subtle
trends like like that
so machines are better at feature
extraction than we are
i shouldn't be telling a computer how to
do its job
the computer should figure out how to do
its job you know no one wants to do that
anyways
so i'm going to let the computer have
fun and i'm going to get back to work
doing what i want to do
so let me see okay oh i'd also like to
mention another startup so
uh i'm sure you guys know who jeremy
howard is a good friend of mine
um so he uh he started a startup called
intilic he was
director of data science at kaggle i
believe i'm sorry if
i'm if i'm butching his position he
watches this later i'm sorry
anyways so he he's actually doing x-ray
and medical imaging
so he's actually trying to help doctors
do early detection of diseases
by automatically taking away like he
takes away a lot of the work
of manually identifying like oh like
that little that little pixel there that
you missed
that was that was actually a disease
that you that you missed
so he's actually working with hospitals
so deep learning is actually used
in a lot like the representation
learning part of it where you can do
automatic trend detection is actually
really good for a lot of very specific
applications
um so another one that's not heralded as
much
like a lot of i've a lot of startups
haven't really tackled this like
all the deep learning startups at this
point that have either been bought or
are out there are either platforms or
have been like
uh images um another one i'd like to
trumpet because
this is my favorite is nlp so textual
representation learning it's actually
taking
sequences of text and figuring out how
like i can actually ask a neural net
how is this word used and how is it
similar to
the other ones and then how does that
map back to the document
that it was present in so deep learning
like again i'm going to show visual
representations of all this so this so
this isn't as clear
i just want you to know what you're
getting yourselves into for those of you
who want to leave early and get bored
i'm previewing everything ahead
so in this case though just to kind of
wrap this up then so text
sequential feature extraction automatic
so it learns how a word is
used and then how would that's then wrap
back up into the document
so deep learning is actually useful
outside of research labs in industry
it's just a lot of people don't know how
to do it or it's way too overpowered or
like
computationally intensive for their
purposes
so again deep learning isn't for
everything but for what it is useful for
if you have any sort of media and you're
spending more more your time doing
feature extraction
then maybe you might want to offload
this to the cpu or gpu because that's
like again gpus computationally
intensive
i'll get into those as well but like
they're great for actually
actually doing this feature analysis at
scale so it's like images and text
the feature space for those are huge
gpus are literally super computers
it's it's kind of cool but like you know
at the end of the day you might want to
cluster
you might want to cluster gpus who's
going to order a cluster gpus
um so i was talking to andrew recently
and he was like yeah um i'm at baidu now
and i
i just like ordered like a thousand gpus
because like i can do that i'm andrew
ing
right but you know at the end of the day
not everybody's going to have that
so use deep learning for what like if
you have a very specific need and human
human capital is being wasted
where cpu could make up for it if that
makes sense
so it is practical but it really just
depends on what you're doing with it and
what resources you have available to you
so what i wanted to kind of get into
first is this idea of representation
learning
and show like well what does a neural
net have to do with all this crap like
you know representation learning feature
learning hierarchies
so this is actually an idea of
representation learning
so in this case if you guys remember the
pixels i was talking about earlier right
i showed it i showed an image and it
literally learned
it starts like at the pixel level zero
to you know so like an image is zero to
255.
usually like you know it's either two or
a 3d matrix depending on if you have the
rgb channels or not
and then what it'll learn over time is
like oh
it automatically learns an edge detector
so the first neural net
is literally an edge detector it's a
hierarchical feature extraction
so what it'll start learning pixels and
then it learns edges
and then next like oh now it's starting
to learn what eyes are
and then eventually you'll get to full
blown faces
so representation learning is this idea
of building a set of general features
by showing up the data and then building
up over time
a higher and higher level representation
of the data that then basically gives
you
a really cool form of dimensionality
reduction as well as a form of
basically automatic feature extraction
so this is this idea of representation
learning
everything starts with you know like
when you have a deep hierarchy
the more deep it is up to four layers
usually
there's more research that's that's
shown that you can have more layers but
usually like
four layers is good enough for most
applications um
that we'll learn this hierarchy that
that we want to learn so
like a neural net is basically like you
know you have you have a set of maybe
three or four neural nets
each of them are stacked and then you
have a classifier on the end
so a neural net is really cool in that
you can actually take
like you know a set of neural nets for
feature extraction and then
toss and toss different classifiers on
the end so i could toss logistic
regression on it
um maximum entropy i could toss an svm
on the end of it
like why not right so it's like um
a good a good example of this is
actually google speech recognition
so they actually use neural nets for
sound and feature
for sound feature detection this is
actually what powers android at this
very moment
and it's been doing it for years um so
what they did was they actually took
the output of a neural net and then
actually slapped a hidden markov bottle
on the end of it
so they just use hidden markov models
with deep learning to
figure out what you're saying and they
used neural nets for the feature
extraction part so when you have
audio when you have unstructured data
that's very hard to interpret
very hard to come up with features for
without you manually spending a lot of
time
then you know slapping something on the
end of it will will do the job just fine
so in this case so hierarchies so neural
nets have activation functions right so
you know just just to kind of clear
things up so i start with the raw data
this is my linear representation and
then i have some sort of i have i have
several different kinds of activations
this could be sigmoid it could be tanh
it could be hard tan h
it could be dropout there's a lot of
different activation functions so i'll
i'm not here to teach you all of deep
learning tonight but if there's any like
particular
knobs or questions you have like if
you've been doing deep learning i'm more
than glad to answer them
but right now like i just want you to be
clear that non-linearity
so anything that basically says oh let
me take the data and
project it onto a new space that's a
non-linearity so very similar to svm
kernels
this idea of activation functions where
it takes the data it takes the output of
the neural net
so for those of you who are math geeks
inputs times weight's plus bias
and then i take i do a non-linear
transform on that so the weights are the
connections
so if you visualize the neural net
connections you have like you have the
circles and then you have the lines that
connect other circles
those are all represented by a matrix
right so that's w
inputs times weights plus bias so i take
that and then i transform it onto some
new decision boundary this could be
sigmoid where it's just like an s
tan h is like another kind of s so
non-linear where
i transform it into something that makes
more sense
that i then pass to the next layer
so from here to here this could be
sigmoid this could be tan h
but what's going to happen here is i'm
going to take the raw pixels and then
basically the nonlinear the
non-linearity it's going to basically
learn
the edges the next one will learn the
faces and it's a series of nonlinear
transforms until you get to the
classifier part
where at that point yes features are are
not really that interpretable
like linear regression linear logistic
regression it's a coefficient per
feature
i know where it's coming from i know how
it's weighted and i can do things with
it
neural net weights have millions of
parameters deep learning
very computationally intensive very ram
intensive hierarchical models
so okay so i i just want to show you
some
this is from software i wrote just just
show you hey i do have experience with
the stuff i wrote my own
i wrote my own library i'm not here to
sell tonight um so i'm going to keep
this minimal
but i just want to show you this is what
a neural net dreams about
so this is actually each neuron learning
a general representation of a face
so you'll see like all i did to do that
all i did reproduce this was
i showed it i basically took i basically
took an image
i turn it into a matrix like just a
feature matrix and then i fed it into
the neural net
it did it ran a few iterations and it
produced this
so this is just the first layer the
first layer
for this is this is specifically from a
restricted bolton machine
for those for when we get into the
nuances later um
a restricted boltzmann machine learns
like tries to learn the whole image at
once
um the image i showed showed you before
is a convolutional neural net
uh for those of you who like who just
who want to know the differences
so the other one was a convolutional
neural net this is the first layer of a
deep leaf network or restricted
boltzmann machine specifically
so it learns a general representation of
faces i like to think of it as a neural
net dreaming
so again nets need training data
so you need a baseline feature vector of
some kind
so what's really nice though is i don't
have to do any sort of like crazy
kernels with it or like take like oh let
me let me apply a solo filter this and
then let me maybe do sift and then let
me like
no so i don't necessarily have to do
that that being said
it will enhance your results if you do
but most of the deep
the the power of deep learning and why
it's meant for production
is this idea of being able to show it
the raw pixels and then
base you might the only thing you may
have to do is probably scale it
and then you'll get the results i was
showing you before so this
so this right here all i did was scale
it with normal with zero meaning unit
variance
and i got and i basically got these i
got these representations
this only took two iterations if you
don't scale the data
just like any other machine learning
algorithm it blows up and dies
so you have to understand not only like
how to tune them but also how to
transform the data
that's just like standard machine
learning
so so in this case like you you need to
construct your feature vectors
so you know there's a lot of
applications of neural nets you know a
lot of them are gonna
you know depending if you're doing
sequential classification with text
you're trying to forecast something
you're trying to just do concrete like
object recognition you know depending on
the kind of application you're doing
you're going to need to vectorize in
some way but the key thing here is that
you can just learn a baseline and then
it will learn
it will learn its own features from
there which is where the accuracy sort
of comes from
so basically what happens is a neural
net basically
basically has its own feedback loop so
it looks at the
basically what it does is you initialize
the weights randomly
so this is for most neural nets you
initialize the weights randomly usually
like
uniform distribution or something like
that it learns like a
like very you have by the way make sure
they're small initialize the weights to
be small
this gives it room to learn and then
what will happen is over time
it will like what it'll do is it'll
literally like look away and be like
let me look at the data uh all right i
can draw it now and then it'll like draw
and then it'll like come back
nope nope nope so it does that with
basically a kl divergence loss function
for those of you who want to
anything again anything in particular
you want to look into just let me know
so kl divergence is basically the
similarity between two probability
distributions
data itself is a distribution so
depending you can actually specify
different probability distributions on
the output
but basically what you do is you
basically minimize the difference and
it's a feedback loop
and that's actually how it learns these
features so this will work for
this will this is a general formula for
basically any neural nets that you're
that you're going to be running into
with deep learning
so you learn these hierarchies by
initially looking at the data and then
you learn
you basically learn the distribution of
the data so that's this idea of
representation learning
depending on the there's several
different kinds of algorithms most
people use gradient ascent but keep in
mind this is not back propagation
like supervised learning this is not
backprop
this is actually this is actually mcmc
and gibbs sampling
you know so neural net weights can also
be learned supervised
some metals only use backprop depending
on the application
some learn how to reconstruct and this
is this is called pre-training
so the pre-trained phase is basically an
initialization phase where it repeatedly
samples the data
until it learns a good representation
this is the part that can take a really
long time
so some people like some data set some
academic papers actually say
oh we took like days to train this it
was awesome
none of you guys want that but so i
don't either which is why like
by default like everything i do is
usually on a cluster or something
but you know it really depends again on
the application
so this is overkill for legend like if
you can just use logistic regression
or random forest or you know whatever
like random classifier you have
that's in r or python or whatever runs
fast for you
you know if you only have a small
feature set throw it in psychic learn or
whatever like r
zero meaning unit variance or scaling
and then classifier you're done
it takes like a minute like this is
overkill for most applications
if you have at scale features where
there's just a lot you need to learn
a high parameter space images images and
text are very are
are great examples of this they're
usually typically they they're either
usually very sparse or very dense both
are both are gigantic feature spaces
that is what neural nets are good for
no one wants to spend spend time coming
up with a million features for
a sparse matrix like oh if this one
feature fires it'll like it'll figure it
out
no i don't want to do that so i'm here
to say
deep learning great for large feature
vectors
and basically learning a representation
of the data
so again just to summarize minimize the
difference between the data
and what the weights output so the
neural net activation
is the reconstruction so basically one
one mechanic one neat mechanic
that i'll show that i'll demonstrate
later is that there's actually two
biases
for the for actually the reconstruction
so for those so again um you guys have
probably seen this before
um credit to andrew ing here um so
this is basically like a so this is your
this is your search space
so gradient descent and all these other
algorithms they go through
they they have a loss function that loss
function is my compass
that says this is my goal and i'm go my
goal is to get to
some kind of a global minimum the global
minimum
for the reconstruction and the neural
nets in this case
is my reconstruction my approximation of
what i was trying to learn with the data
so those representations you were
learning
those come up when this is down here so
just again just to make sure we we kind
of clarify
oops okay faces
are at that global minimum so each
neuron
this is actually a weight matrix so the
neural nets learn how to reconstruct
that and it does it by
doing like by minimizing the loss
function between
the the the data and what it what it
randomly outputs so you get the weights
you get the weights to look like this
with this this is called representation
learning
so representation learning i wanna i
wanna i wanna make that a buzzword i'm
trying to like
i'm trying to clean a term here so
representation learning is this idea of
saying
i have abstract features and i want to
learn them
i've i've drilled this enough i just
want to make sure that you guys kind of
get like
the signal you guys have a slide to take
a picture of if you want to
if you want something with
representation learning but i think i've
drilled
drill drilled home enough like what
you're what you're trying to do here
so okay so deep learning um
just just to kind of just kind of go
crazy with this so i mentioned video
games earlier
so representation learning good for
learning features
so again like time series images
doesn't matter so it can be used for
creepy purposes
not all of us like not you know big data
kind of
we're all data scientists but yeah what
can you do
so it's true though right
so deep learning um breakthrough
representations and sentiment analysis
so i don't know if you guys saw the
uh the the recent output by stanford
last year
where they actually did basically
literally record-breaking accuracy
in sentiment analysis and they literally
did it by actually
basically creating a neural net that was
a tree so you actually have a neural net
that's actually represented by a binary
tree
with weights at each node and you
literally have the likelihood of a
context
represented every node and then that
that was that was that was the baseline
for uh movie review sentiment analysis
so there's actually a kaggle competition
on this it's the rotten tomatoes data
set if you guys want to take a look at
it
so now let's let's let's actually get
into some neural nets now so
this is a restricted boltzmann machine
so
it's a two layer neural net right so
you have literally the visible and the
hidden
so the hidden is the reconstructions i
was showing you earlier
and basically what happens if you guys
remember the learning and the hill and
all that other fun stuff
what's happening here is you have you
basically have the inputs so you have
the inputs down here
clamped onto the visible weights and
then what you have
so these are this is your weight matrix
this is and then this is your visible
bias
and what you have and then this is your
hidden byte so these are actually all
biases
and what you have is you you basically
have a feedback loop
that learns how to reconstruct the data
so you you matrix
you basically sample from the true
that's your prior
you show and then you basically
propagate this up
to the hidden the hidden has its
representation and then it comes back
down
prop up prop down and then it's
literally a feedback loop that learns
how to reconstruct data
so this is a two layer neural net so
this is one of those feature extractors
so like
if we remember like if we remember the
three different like the the
hierarchical features
this is one this is a neural net that
learns features specifically
so this is for feature extraction
so okay so did you get did you guys i
i hope you're following me here so it's
like i have these feature extracting
neural nets and then i have
these classifier neural nets so deep
belief networks deep belief networks
have been hyped for a long time
used in a lot of applications this is
this is jeff hinton's thing
so deep belief networks are stacked
restricted bulk
machines you basically have a set of
feature extractors and then you have
logistic regression or something on the
end
so your output function is configurable
though which is really cool
so i have a series of stacked restricted
bolts machines that learn that that can
learn features
and then i have some sort of output so
this can be any number of layers
so this is the deep part of it uh deep
leaf network with mnist for example
um the typical number of parameters i
end up with is a million
that's just for 784 pixels and then i
reduce it at each layer so
a deep belief network over time says i
have 784 on the input and then
i want to learn how to reconstruct this
with only 500 hidden units
so the hidden units are those faces that
you that you saw earlier that's those
feature reconstructions
it's actually a dimensionality reduced
representation of the data
that can actually either improve on the
data by getting rid of errors in the
data
or at least at the very minimum
approximates it but it's an automatic
form of dimensionality reduction so what
you do is you take the output of that
and pass it to the next layer the next
layer and then what you get on the end
in this case like if i have a deep leaf
network 784 on the on the inputs
that's a straight feature vector 28 by
28 image i
i flatten it yes flattening it actually
is fine
i i know i know it destroys con like it
doesn't actually destroy context and
structure as much as you think it would
so anyways just bear with me on that 784
pixels
500 250 100
10. so 10 is the number of labels in the
endness dataset in this case
so the reason i'm harping mnist is
because it's what you see in all the
tutorials
uh it's what you'll see on
deepointing.net and a lot of the other
deep learning frameworks that are out
there
um so this is typically like what this
is typically what happens then so
i stack them and then it learns a
classifier and then what you get is an
automatic form of eventuality reduction
so the future learning that happens and
the representations
are basically an approximation of the
data with compression
so a deep belief network is i'll
correct me if i'm wrong google i believe
uses a
moving window deep belief network for
their for their uh
for their future extraction of audio but
i know hinton's there so i'm assuming
that that's what it is but
who knows either way great results
on both sequential tasks as well as just
normal classification
so one one thing i wanted one one neat
thing i want to demonstrate was this
idea of semantic hashing
so a deep auto encoder basically is a
deep belief network
and the transpose of another deep belief
network
so you have an encoder you pre-train it
very similar to what
i had mentioned earlier so you do
pre-trained pre-trained pre-trained
and then what you actually do is you
take the neural net and then you
actually transpose it
so you flip the weights and then what
you get is you actually get the output
you actually get the input
on the output and what you get in the
middle is actually a
basically literally a condensed form of
the data that you can use for
compression in a search engine
so you can say i can basically learn how
to reconstruct this
into a short binary code that allows me
to basically
basically represent the data
so what does that actually look like so
this is actually on bag of words
so this is on the reuters the reuters
news group data set
it took basically the binary codes are
very similar to pca
i i basically reduce it down to two to
ten two to ten digits
i took the first two like so you take
the first two
um like of the binary codes so you
compress it down to two numbers
and then you can actually plot it and
you you can actually see that the
decision boundary
is very clear like you don't have to you
really don't have to do much
this is literally completely
unsupervised
so the only back propagation that
happened it was on the input itself so i
didn't have any additional labels or
anything
and it learns a good representation of
the data
so you can use this for any form of
media
that will actually learn how to
reconstruct whatever the input was
and what you get is this crazy form of
dimension reduction and compression
so another one so this is actually done
by flickr
is this idea of image search so what
happens
is those those binary codes i learned
earlier
i can actually show it an image and then
based on those binary codes
this is this this is actually what it
will produce
as you can see based on those the binary
codes are actually a good very good
representation
no supervised learning involved at all
all i had to do was show up the data
and then it learns literally the art
like based on the raw rgb channels
it learns how to compress those rgb
channels into a binary code that then
represe like that is that is similar to
other binary codes in that space
completely unsupervised the only thing
you do is backprop on the input data
itself
so once you've done the baseline
featurization you're good to go
so again this is like for so image
search just to be clear
is i upload an image and then it's
basically give me back similar images
no manual feature extraction involved
all i had to do was just kind of
take the rgb take the rgb values shove
them into the neural net
it learns how to it learns how to
compress them that will scale
with whatever data you're trying to do
like however many features you have and
whatever else
this is why most of the crazy research
labs are doing this kind of stuff now
because i can do something like this
image search is a very hard problem
that's used by a lot of companies so
again
so again this was this was text and
topic modeling
so this was topic modeling this was
image search
both different kinds of information
retrieval
both are based on these idea binary
codes i can actually plot those binary
codes and actually use those as features
so i basically get this really cool form
of image compression the wasp function
here is just the reconstruction of the
input
and then what i get in the middle is
literally basically a condensed version
of the data
all right so that's enough about deep
leaf networks debug encoders semantic
hashing
let's get into a little bit in the
convolutional maps now so you guys have
you i don't know you guys have probably
seen uh convolutional nets before
uh yad lacoom loves talking about him um
he's a director of facebook's ai lab in
new york
so convolutional nats are literally
they're really cool so what i can
actually do with the convolutional mat
is i can actually learn something called
a feature map so what i'll do
is i have this very limited view of the
world and i do it like i literally do a
moving window and then
i so with this view i superimpose
other things and mix and match features
so what i get is actually a general
representation of the data
based on mixes and so what that's going
to allow me to do is if i have
if i showed it if i show a convolutional
not an image it actually can take a
posing it can automatically do
pose and variant feature extraction so
it doesn't matter if i'm standing like
this
if my head sideways it will actually it
will actually figure all that stuff out
for you
so convolutional nets have several
variants but the core the core concept
here
is this idea of feature maps and a
moving window over
uh different subsets of the data
so another one recursive neural tester
networks
so recursive neural tensor networks are
used in a lot of crazy applications
so they're a little they're the new kid
on the scene
um recursive neural nets there's also
recurrent nets so don't confuse the two
where current gnats are usually time
series recursive is more for media
analysis
so recursive basically are used for are
basically used for hierarchical feature
learning
so recursive neural nets are a tree
recurrent neural nets
are like basically basically a form of
shared weights
across basically across like a series so
recursive knowledge is our tree so
used in sequential applications um i
don't know if you guys have seen word
vectors at all
um so word vectors are basically like
well what i'll show here in a little bit
basically this idea of
let me let me learn the usage of a word
so that was what that was basically what
was demonstrated earlier
so what i do is i take those word
vectors and
since they are they represent an
individual token it's a vector per word
not
not a so it's a vector not account for
word keep that in mind
so it's a vector i basically take that
attach it to the leaf node
and then literally so it's a binary tree
you learn the parent nodes
or actually the likelihood of a
particular context so i have the parents
or i have the children
the children are the word vectors and
then each one each
each parent up is in a likelihood of
their context
so let me show you an example with
images so
scene parsing so scene parsing is
breaking up an image into segments and
automatically doing feature extraction
the analogy so the analogy to this in
traditional application traditional
sequential applications are conditional
random fields
so typically using nlp as well as image
segmentation
so you break up a pixel into a set of
quadrants
and then you basically build a tree of
those of those quadrants
and then what you do is you say okay
this all represents a house
so that's what i was taught that's what
i was talking about with with the tree
you'll notice like i said everything's
kind of binary like there's different
there's different features there's
different
parts of an image or whatever attached
to the neural net
and then what you get at the top is is
this a house or not
or maybe i can go down further and say
well okay maybe
maybe this part's grass this part is
whatever
so obviously you have to like there is a
lot of recursion involved
it's a tree right so um so basically the
output of these is literally like
it's literally a soft fact on each node
so you you basically matrix multiply the
two nodes
and you take a soft max of it and then
that gives you a probability
distribution of the cloud oh basically a
given context
so each content like so what context is
a supervised application
um there's also recursive auto encoders
as well so you can actually do
literally so in this case like i can
actually do like top
down so for crop backpack four top
right prop it's it's up and down so
i can actually do so i can actually have
the input at the top and then like
different parts of the box
and then i can actually learn how to
reconstruct the data with that as well
um typically used with gradient descent
momentum and adaptive future work i
don't know if you guys have seen
autograd or not but
adaptive linearts so
again sequential applications we can
break up a sentence
very similarly with this idea of
constituency parsing
so i basically basically for text you
run
you you run a constituency parser on the
sentence
you get a binary tree out that binary
tree is then mapped
mapped onto word vectors and then each
node of the constituency parts is then
uh basically has a likelihood of
occurring or not
and then that's actually how you do
composition of different kind of media
all right let's see we're right here uh
can i get a time
ten minutes awesome oh wow that's
perfect okay
all right um okay so i can get into
um i can't notice a little bit so this
is just what a constituency part looks
like
so in this case i have i have part of
speech tags that are basically a part of
speech tags as parents
and the words at the bottom so remember
these are each word vectors
if that makes sense so then and then at
the top i have
uh i basically have the whole sentence
like the likelihood of this being
positive or negative so this is um so
the application that they did was
sentiment analysis here so
in this case like i have spans of text
so span some text i basically break it
up into tokens
i take the tokens turn it into a tree
with the part of speech tagger
and then i create this binary tree that
represents the sentence
and then i classify the likelihood of
individual contacts
what's interesting about that is if i'm
doing sentiment analysis i can
if i can say not happy and happy i can
actually have
different nodes with different
likelihoods which allows me to actually
segment a sentence up properly
that's obviously that's gonna so that's
that's what that's way more useful over
back it works
when you're trying to do when you're
trying to you know trying to do name
recognition
relation extraction or really any
information or treatment tasks
so again sequential applications
so so one one visualization technique i
like using
is called tsme pieceme so t distributed
stochastic neighborhood
so this is uh this is pcn steroids
basically what it does is it actually it
runs something
something that's basically approximately
the k nearest neighbor search
and basically basically creates
basically does a form of dimensionality
reduction
that learns how to automatically group
the data so when i'm trying to when i'm
trying to debug representations
like faces by the same person should be
near the same person
right so what i do is i actually reduce
the i
should reduce the representation that
that was learned
down to down to two dimensions and then
i can apply
so this is this is useful with any form
of media that you're going to be doing
um my favorite my favorite application
of this is obviously going to be text
with images i already have the renders
so i can actually see what the neural
net is picturing
and then what it's representing like
what this interpretation of data is
with text that's a lot harder to do but
if i can map the distances and plot them
and see like oh um
two is next to three like that makes
sense to me i know that these word
vectors are good
so this is great for actually
visualizing the global structure of the
data
so again tsa
i think so this is just an example
from some of my own work where i i know
it's very hard to see
um this is on the eminence digits so
what i did was i i
so i created a representation of the ns
digits and then
i actually had a group like what you'll
see is like this is actually all six is
over here
this is like all twos here's like eights
over here so it learns actually how to
group the data it's a really cool form
of dimensionality reduction
and i will take questions
so okay so the question was
how long would it correct me if i'm
wrong how long would it take to read all
the
to learn politicians faces give me like
a technical
feasibility oh so well
so there's a big enough corpus out there
so if i want to learn
every face in the world um facebook is a
great api
um i would probably go work there if i
wanted to do that though um that's
actually the focus of facebook's ai lab
is learning every face in the world and
being able to identify who you are
so technical feasibility huge scale
um how does performance of neural nets
things like name etsy recognition
compared
um so it be it be it beats the pants off
of everything that's domain specific for
nlp
um so any sequential application it is
either done it is either done
record-breaking or it is like
completely destroyed i don't i replaced
so i used to do nlp with only just like
conditional rhino fields max n models i
used to do that
i only do deep learning now for text
especially for sequential applications
look into the different word vector
representations for sequential
applications
so as someone that knows a lot about
machine learning but
is new to deep learning um what's the
easiest and most approachable way to
learn deep learning
one on my laptop two on my big cluster
of work
um so there's a lot of there's a lot of
different frameworks out there
so fianna so yeah exactly so
fianno i would i would start actually
with piano because it's really easy to
build your own neural nets there
um so if you want to so like because
it'll automatically do the gradient
calculations for you and all the other
crazy stuff and it's very easy to
prototype a lot of applications
um if you want to if you want so if you
want a partner type kind of cluster
um there's a few deporting frameworks
out there um
i didn't want to do this um but there's
there's h2o
um but there's also there's and then
there's also my framework which does
descriptive gpus
cool um so um so it's
on your cluster like there's the the
problem with a lot of distributed neural
nets is that
the the different algorithms um out
there are like
it's kind of crazy like there's hog wild
there's sandmaster of the fgs
there's like and then there's our play
in the field which is interview reviews
um all of those are a different set of
math and a different set of rules
relative to
other deep learning so there's a little
bit of a higher learning curve which is
why we just like start with
fianna and like mini batch learning and
then kind of go into that because the
cluster is a different segment
so before i put my knit in should i
clean it up or leave it as it is
oh sorry um so so he asked
what should i do should i clean my data
up before actually feeding it to a
neural net
so uh it depends on the sort of data
right so if you're doing text you're
still going to want to be stemming
you're still going
because like in this case like word
vectors have the site still have this
idea of the focal
you know garbage in garbage out no
matter what you're doing so yeah always
clean up your data
streaming data from a sensor well so
you're
okay so that so if you so depend your
data pipeline should be the same for
training and casting
so your data that should automatically
data cleaning should automatically be
integrated into your data pipeline
that's usually more of a data engineer's
concern that being said like
if your data pipeline is consistent
you're not classifying the right set of
name
uh so uh we all like accuracy but the
flip side to that coin to me is actually
palatability
uh so uh if i'm using a deep learning in
uh say fraud detection uh would i be
able to actually assign a reason
for that no so i at the beginning of
this talk i basically said neural nets
are utter crap
for actually feature introspection you
do not want to do it
i don't i don't really want to see you
like stick her in a forest like i don't
i don't want to be sued because you need
to be audited
like neural nets are all for media
media media there is no like in human
interpretive representation of a pixel
like neural nets are good for basically
they're they're
basically they're better than a set of
hacks for feature extraction
that's media oh sorry um
so he asked uh what is it good for for
feature introspection and architecture
okay some of us are stuck with the
experience of being on the hadoop spark
stack and
so open source so any recommendations so
oh
quit getting me to sell my own framework
um so i actually built um
so i'd like to announce that i'm
actually i'm actually writing an
o'reilly book
i actually closed the deal with o'reilly
to do deep learning like hadoop and
spark
um so my framework actually integrates
with hadoop and spark
um we're going to be releasing in jvm to
do versions soon so i wrote a deporting
framework for the jvm
um there's another framework called h2o
they only have a deeply network though
and i don't know i don't know how their
community like so i don't know
much i don't know what other community
is i personally do training
um i'll talk offline about that though
but yeah so for jbm and spark
like that's the reason i exist basically
in fact if that explains anything
how does it deal with uh like mixed
media so
a mixture of audio and video so
that's actually okay so he asked he
asked how does deep learning handle a
mixture of data so
that's actually what deporting is
actually really good at
is actually taking mixtures of data
because when we said this representation
learning
like the goal is to actually be able to
throw just whatever whatever data i
wanted to learn
whatever mixture of distributions as
long as you label it properly like
okay if i have audio if i have video and
images in one
and i want to say this so this audio is
this person talking and then this is the
person talking
it will actually be able to figure that
out so unsupervised so that's what
representation learning is good for is
actually being able to mix different
kinds of media
one more question um
not necessarily people's data
um yeah so uh deep learning in general
is very good at
like being able so it's actually one of
the best road detectors in the world so
deep learning's primarily primarily
application is actually
facial detection images so identifying
missing people and all that and other
like fun stuff as well like facebook
does this at scale being able to
identify individual people's faces
um so it's actually very possible to do
that with and what's really nice is like
with unsupervised with the unsupervised
representation learning
you can show it like different kinds of
images and it will learn like oh this is
like
this is like the face of like an agent
and then this is the face of a woman or
whatever
so the representation learning is
actually especially good for that kind
of stuff
so i was going to stick around for a
little while to answer questions
personally
so let's think of a great talk